the plane was coming into land at the
small city of bukoba in Tanzania this
Airport runway ends on the shore of Lake
Victoria Africa's largest lake
when the aircraft was about 100 meters
of mid-air it encountered problems and
bad weather it was raining and the plane
plunged into the water everything is
under control the Army's head of rescue
missions and firefighters from the
province of kagera are on the scene they
are fully equipped to deal with rescues
and safety rescue efforts are currently
underway in order to retrieve the
aircraft
the plane belongs to precision air
tanzania's largest privately owned
Airline its propeller-powered planes
carry passengers between Tanzanian
cities and to neighboring countries
we have already informed the Prime
Minister also we have received the
condolences from the president of the
United Republic of Tanzania he has
agreed to more resources for the rescue
effort for the remaining people
domestic flights are a crucial part of
tanzania's Transport sector
cross-country Road Journeys can take
days for those who can afford it air
travel is much quicker and usually safer
Malcolm Webb Al Jazeera